we're looking at today what are we
looking at today we're measuring
triangles evidently nothing should have
a special way in fact I'll tell you in a
minute but I just want to notice what is
going on because we're mathematicians
see something like this we like to call
this in the business a smoking gun
because I'm you can see clearly with the
exception of maybe one or two know this
it seems to be a patent right now it's
not like it's it's not all the numbers
are identical I'm really glad you can
see some people drew some huge triangles
and some ones over here on the
right-hand column for each of the
triangles you'll notice there pretty
much all of these numbers pretty much
all they all cluster around this ratio
did you notice that and maybe you didn't
take you very long time look at the
people next to you and in the same way
over here all of the numbers they cost
around this ratio nothing up my sleeves
and just right now is already prepared
now this is a mystery
this is a mystery okay in fact it's one
of two mysteries we're going to explore
today mystery number one is how did I
know how did I know that this was going
to be like I said to you I made a big
point through whatever triangle you like
and it's all have drawn completely
different triangles and no way of
predicting what links you were going to
have but I knew there was going to be
this ratio 1 to 2 maybe there was going
to be the 1 2 3
okay so efficient number one how did I
done how did I get secondly more
fundamentally like why would to try to
lose do this mathematicians talk about
shapes and functions and
and we speaking about their behaving in
certain ways and having certain
characteristics as if there were people
with personalities right but they're
just shapes right maybe no okay so what
I want us to explore is underneath when
you've written all this okay a little
something-something is ratios in
triangles okay now what we were
comparing all these different lengths
and then we mentioned all this out there
just to rewind when all this start
I didn't give you any lengths all I gave
you was what kinds of missions did I
give you for you for the beginning I
gave you angles right so I gave you 30
degrees here the 19 degrees
okay so what's happening here is ratios
in triangles see how this it actually
will leave with the angles of the
triangles okay so the first unit right
is these seem to be defined by the
angles now you'll notice I said ain't
girls plural not angles singular angles
in your life because I said 30 degrees
which seems like I just wonder what Abel
and I said 19 degrees which seems like
it's just one angle but I couldn't need
you in the fact that I actually don't
every single angle in your triangle just
by saying this how do I know it's
actually something I haven't written on
the board which I told you at the
beginning as well as the page what else
- I also said I wanted to be a
right-angled triangle right so not only
do you have the 30 degrees but you also
have the 90 degrees and because trials
only have three angles in them they are
called triangles after all I go that the
third angle has to be equal to only one
knows only one thing it can be assuming
of course that we can measure well I've
have a look if you've got a 38 at 90
what does the last angle have to be
yes they succeed because who had the
angle summer triangle is 180 degrees and
you can replay the signal here for this
triangle again I told you to make it
right good which makes the final angle
71 now just a little pause I'm here on
top of your tables you may want to write
this word is very hopeful see this 230
and this 60 right the 19 degrees and the
71 we call these guys of complements
complements not is it like hey nice
haircut Akhil
I only know comments with an E as you
this wine goes with this dish really
really well okay so 1364 compliments 19
and 71 also continents okay so what we
noticed is these seem to be defined by
the angles you know what the egg was are
the angles will tell you what's going on
with these ratios okay but the question
is why what I would like angles is
something to do with rotation like how
far you turned around whereas this is
all about the lengths okay so why are
they connected and this is why I gave a
good check now see how long this takes
me to do here and you'll need to draw
something like this in your in your book
here is the explanation as to why
knowing something about the angles has
to tell you something about theirs has
to tell you something about the sides as
well because um one um what topic are we
in right now to get much a Koi mm three
and the name is similarity because when
you have a look at all of the triangles
that you have made and you all made
different ones well as you can see
pretty clearly what's going on right
what what are all of these shapes and
how they're related to each other they
are basically the same shape all that's
different is that is the size right now
think back yes the colors are different
you feed back to that oh no I did think
back to the beginning is topic what I
said
similar figures I gave you a definition
for these shapes right I came just going
to stop because I'm running out of these
things are just squishing up top of each
other similar figures right they have
two things in common and one thing
different what are the things that all
similar figures have in common with each
other what do they have in common okay
so before I took many angles right I
talked about like their shoes to each
other their proportions proportions and
then I also talked about their features
just like as in it's not the same number
size they were white angles that Kofi so
if you can see maybe in case your side
of the room or something I mean kind of
quite see it by giving you by defining
the angles okay what you had no choice
in doing is if I once you know two
angles that's a lie gate right the 30 in
the 90 or the 19 at the 90 by telling
you two angles that forces the third one
to be the same if all the angles are the
same then everything else also ends up
being the same it's just sighs that ends
up being different does that kind of
make sense so here's our explanation
they seem to be defined by the angles
and the reason why the reason why this
is because having equal angles forces
the triangles to be similar they have to
be you can pick in fact any three angles
you like that add up to 180 degrees
which will form a triangle they don't
have to be 30 90 60 or 19 1971 any three
angles you like and if you start doing
this exercise again and cutting out some
more they're all going to end up being
similar to each other they can't do
anything else they have to be okay